bonjour avoue caroline de camaret vous
êtes le chef du service europe ici à
france 24 vous suit avec attention les
derniers développements autour de ce
sommet caroline l'enjeu principal
objectif c'est ce que je disais à
l'instant c'est de priver finalement
moscou 2-2 l'argent du gaz et du pétrole
et tenter de stopper le financement de
cette guerre aussi alors je rejoindrai
d'ailleurs ce sommet à 4h à son
démarrage effectivement et vous me
retrouverez à versailles vous êtes sur
les fronts mais effectivement ce qu'il
ya d'intéressant c'est que finalement
les états unis ont poussé les européens
sans les prévenir un peu dans leurs
retranchements puisque eux ont décrété
un embargo sur le pétrole et le gaz ce
qui met vraiment mal à l'aise les
européens alors sur le pétrole ça
représente 20% de notre dépendance pour
soi pour les américains droit l'a pas
tout à fait dans la même dépendance
enfin oui mais mais c'est un portable le
pétrole aaa au prix en effet mais c'est
une matière qui est beaucoup plus un
portable que ne l'est le gaz qui dépend
lui de 'pipeline' et donc du jour au
lendemain on ne peut pas trouver de
nouveaux 'pipeline' et l'union
européenne en dépend à 40% et en effet
vous avez raison entre les états membres
il ya de grâce grandes divergences
puisque la france dépend à peine à 20%
du gaz russe quand l'allemagne dépend à
55% et certains pays comme la lettonie
la république tchèque ou la finlande à
100% donc vous voyez effectivement que
c'est très difficile pour nous de
décréter du jour au lendemain cet
embargo qui effectivement aurait des
répercussions fortes sur moscou et
j'aimerais beaucoup vladimir poutine
dans sa campagne ukrainienne il
n'empêche mardi il ya eu toute une
communication déjà de la commission
européenne qui a élaboré un plan pour
d'ici la fin de l'année réduire aux deux
tiers notre dépendance notamment en
augmentant nos capacités de stockage à
90 % en septembre pour passer le
prochain hiver donc on y pense beaucoup
mais certains estiment d'ores et déjà
que c'est trop peu et puis certains
veulent une date butoir pour se
débarrasser totalement notre dépendance
au gaz russe qui serait 2025 d'autres
disent 2030 certains disent qu'il ne
faut surtout pas de date butoir parce
que justement on n'est pas du tout au
même niveau entre les pays européens
ça va être une des grandes discussions
de ce sommet de versailles à un les pays
du sud
particulier l'espagne l'italie la grèce
et dans une certaine mesure la france
veulent aussi plus d'action pour faire
baisser le prix de l'énergie parce qu'il
considère que pour leurs populations
cette envolée des prix est insoutenable
et notamment avoir peut-être court
encore à un grand emprunt encore à une
dette en commun à un nouveau plan de
relance tout le cela est sur la table
les pays frileux on les connaît un ce
sont toujours les frigos en particulier
les pays bas et cetera mais cette c'est
une discussion qui a le mérite d'avoir
lieu et qui pourrait peut-être mettre à
rude épreuve cette unité est une autre
question hautement importante qui sera
abordé dont vous prendrai certainement
tout à l'heure quand vous y serez aussi
à 16 heures c'est la question de
l'adhésion de l'ukraine à l'union
européenne bien sûr parce que lui parce
que le président zélande ce qui a
demandé une procédure accélérée
d'adhésion de son pays à l'union
européenne en pleine guerre ça n'est pas
tout à fait jouable alors dans la foulée
d'ailleurs la géorgie et la moldavie qui
ont aussi des conflits jolie gelé avec
moscou eh bien on demandé la même chose
et le même traitement de faveur la
commission européenne on lui a demandé
de rendre sa copie dès aujourd'hui pour
savoir si c'est souhaitable faisable et
c'est van der leyen ursula von der leyen
sa présidente dans un premier temps elle
n'a pas été très prudente parce qu'elle
a commencé à ébaucher une vocation
européenne etc il faut comprendre que
l'adhésion à l'union et l'adhésion à
l'otan sont les deux pierres angulaires
de la colère de vladimir poutine sur ce
flanc est et que les européens ne
peuvent pas trop jouer avec le feu alors
ils vont quand même dans un communiqué
final dire qu'il faut renforcer les
liens économiques et donner des
perspectives économiques fortes à ces
pays du flanc est mais en revanche une
adhésion à leurs dents dans un contexte
de guerre est très difficile puisque
cette ukraine ne remplirait pas les
critères de stabilité politique et
démocratique ce qui a aussi des
problèmes de corruption qui sont
nécessaires pour justement passer
l'étape de l'adhésion alors après à
l'autre question c'est ce que cette
adhésion la protègerait nous protège
potentiellement l'ukraine est déjà en
guerre mais les autres pays par exemple
comme la géorgie et la moldavie bien il
ya en effet dans les traités
dans le traité d'adhésion un article de
défense qui est assez contraignant le
42,7 qui oblige assistance mutuelle
comme d'ailleurs l'article 5 de l'otan
mais pour autant et bien en effet
l'union européenne n'est pas un projet
militaire et donc une adhésion pour
l'instant en tout cas ne sera pas ne
sera pas accordée ni en vitesse
accélérée nie dans les termes que le
souhaiterez l'ukraine et ses voisins
merci beaucoup car